RON: All right,
welcome to authors
at Google here in Los Angeles.
Normally we begin author
events with reading
a short bio of the speaker
downloaded from the internet
or emailed to us by a publicist.
Well, I encourage everyone
to google Dr. Daniel Siegel
and read about the
schools he attended
and books he published.
It is perhaps a better use
of the short time allotted
for introduction to explain
why it is so exciting to have
Dr. Siegel here at Google
talking about adolescence.
The other day, a
friend of mine said
this about his 16-year-old son.
Two years ago, he said,
we were best buddies.
Now all I am to him is a
driver and an a ATM machine.
Another friend offered the
following pearl of wisdom.
Yes, teenagers want
nothing to do with you,
and they can't
wait to leave home.
But don't worry.
They'll be back when they're 23.
These two quotes are typical
of how the grownup world views
adolescents as inaccessible,
a great big black hole,
a terrible thing we
need to get through
as best we can until a grownup
emerges on the other side
and we can finally breathe
a huge sigh of relief.
Grownups and adolescents find
each other frustrating and
infuriating.
I suspect that some
of you are parents
who came to this
talk hoping for tips
on how to handle
their teenagers.
And yes, Daniel Siegel's
book "Brainstorm"
provides a richness of
insight and practical advice
to meet that need.
But what makes this
book truly revolutionary
is its insistence that
adolescence is not a problem
to be tackled but
an opportunity,
an amazing opportunity to be
cultivated and celebrated.
Those same brain changes that
can cause so much anguish
have the potential, if
correctly understood,
to not only be a source
of great satisfaction
but in fact to
quote from the book,
"they can enable adolescents
to go on and lead
great lives of
adventure and purpose."
Reading the book, you discover
that the aggravation normally
associated with adolescence
is an unnecessary cost
of how we deal with it.
Furthermore, hallmarks
of adolescence
are youthful energy, creativity,
passion, original thought,
and a panache for
social connectivity.
These are resources that are now
wasted on a gargantuan scale.
A better understanding
of the brain
can allow adolescents to
make use of these gifts
towards the making of a better
society and a better world.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Daniel Siegel.
DANIEL SIEGEL: Thank you, Ron.
That was beautiful.
Thank you, Ron.
That was really beautiful.
Can you hear me all right?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
DANIEL SIEGEL: Great.
Well, it's an honor to be
here with you at Google.
This is my fourth Google
campus that I'm visiting.
And this one is local, so
it's an easier trip for me.
So it's really great to be here.
What I'm going to do is
give you a short overview
of the ideas in
"Brainstorm: The Power
and Purpose of
the Teenage Brain"
and look at some myths
about adolescence
and what are the actual truths.
And by understanding
the truths, we actually
empower adolescents
and adults who
care for adolescents or
actually any adult who
once was an adolescent
to actually reclaim
a certain aspect of celebrating
this period of life.
So we'll then take
time for a discussion.
Because if it's like past
experience I've had at Google,
it's really great
to actually make
this more interactive
in a discussion period.
So I'll leave time for that too.
So first let me
just check with you.
How many of you have adolescents
at home right at this moment?
OK, so there's probably
a sense of urgency then.
How many of you
have younger kids
at home and you're
getting ready for them
to turn into adolescents?
Great, and how many of
you once were adolescents?
Anyone?
Great, so that's
pretty much everyone.
So for myself, I come
from a background where
basically I trained in
science and biochemistry
and then went on to medicine
and then became a psychiatrist
after training initially
in pediatrics and then
adult psychiatry, became a child
and adolescent psychiatrist.
And then when I was
trained in research,
I was really beginning
at the period which
was called the decade
of the brain, 1990.
And so it became an
incredible opportunity
to actually take the
science of the brain
and try to apply it to practical
clinical use in psychiatry.
And so I worked to help
create a field called
interpersonal neurobiology.
And that field basically takes
all the different disciplines
of science and puts them
together into one framework.
And so we have now 36
textbooks that I've
edited in that series.
And just to show you
just some examples,
these are other books besides
the "Brainstorm" book.
This is basically
just so you know
where the science we're about
to talk about comes from.
This is a graduate
school textbook
that I wrote called "The
Developing Mind," which
basically takes all these
different fields of science
and combines them into one.
If you like non-linear
books, this book,
"The Interpersonal
Neurobiology Pocket Guide"
is actually written
in a non-linear way.
So especially if
it's on a tablet,
you can bounce around
wherever you feel like going
and learn all about this field.
And if you have younger kids,
a book I wrote with my student
now colleague,
Tina Payne Bryson,
"The Whole-Brain
Child," will talk
about a lot of
what we're talking
about now applied
to younger children.
So in my own case,
I have not just
worked in the field of
interpersonal neurobiology
but also have worked at home
with my partner and wife,
Caroline Welch,
where we were deeply
trying to raise our kids,
who are now almost 20 and 24.
In fact, our son is
traveling around the world,
and just two days ago I
got back from spending
two weeks with him after
not seeing him for a year.
And it's true.
When they get in their mid-20s,
there's this wonderful change.
And it was an
incredible opportunity.
And these kids in their 20s that
we have are still adolescents.
So the first myth
I want identify
is that people use
the term adolescents
synonymously with
the term teenager.
And that's just not true.
The adolescent
period can be defined
as a period between
childhood and adulthood.
And there was a
debate a while ago,
should we just get rid
of the term adolescence?
Is it meaningless?
Is there just childhood
dependency and then
adult responsibility?
But it turns out that not just
in people who live on the West
Coast or people who are
human beings but actually
many mammals have an
adolescent period, which
is distinct from childhood
and distinct from adulthood.
So it isn't just we
that have this period.
Now, what is this
period all about?
Well, it's not just about
having a number that
begins with teen,
like 19, or 18, or 17.
It turns out that
there are changes
in the brain that we didn't
know about before 15 years ago
that identify that the
adolescent period is more
than just going
through puberty, which
is sexual maturation, which
now begins, by the way,
much earlier than it ever has.
And the period
following puberty,
which is the adolescent
period generally--
it doesn't always
work that way--
but this period of, if you
will, a developmental time when
you're not just
dependent on adults
but you're not just working
with adult responsibility
of raising a family
or having work.
This period between has a
certain purpose and power to it
that we never really
understood before.
So for many adults,
even when you just
approach the teenage
years, you say, oh my gosh.
My kid is going
to be a teenager.
I don't know what's
going to happen.
You have a lot of trepidation.
And what we're about to
do is identify the myths
that when you
understand them you
can have celebration,
not trepidation.
And what are the basic
ways that the brain
is changing that can identify
these myths and clarify them?
So the first thing is that
the adolescent period is not
just the teenage years.
That's the first myth.
That changes in the brain happen
between around 12 years of age
more or less-- a little
bit younger in girls,
a little bit older in boys,
but it's around the same --
just around now before
the teenagers begin.
And it ends in the mid-20s.
And the ending is of what?
It's actually of a
period of brain change
that's called remodeling.
So this remodeling period is
happening into the mid-20s.
And by understanding the
nature of the remodeling,
we actually can understand
a lot about what
adolescents go through.
So let's just review very
briefly the brain in general.
Let's talk about how
the brain interacts
with culture, and family life,
and interaction with peers.
And let's look at then why
a child's experience may be
different from an adolescent's,
which may be different from
an adult's.
So Ron was really
nice to actually come
early this morning and tape
underneath your chair a model
of the brain that you get
to take home with you.
So if you reach underneath
your chair with your arm
and then pull your
arm out, you'll
notice there's a hand
attached to your arm.
And this is a handout
for you for today.
If you fold your thumb in
the middle of your hand
and fold your
fingers over the top,
this brain would be oriented
in your hand like that.
My daughter says, never say
it's a handy model of the brain,
but it is.
It's very handy
because it actually
is a pretty good example of
how the brain is structured.
So before we get to
the details, let's
give the first very
brief overview of brain
anatomy, function,
and development.
Genes play a very
important role in how
the basic cells of the
brain, the neurons,
will link up to each other.
And even the supportive
cells, the glial cells,
oligodendrocytes and astrocytes
will perform functions
that we don't even understand.
It's a big, big mystery, but
the parts we do understand
are these.
That the way neurons
get connected
influence how you think, how
you feel, and how you behave.
So thinking, feeling, behavior
is a part of our mental life.
So in this way, we say that
the structure of the brain
influences its function, and
the function of the brain
influences in part mental life.
So when we say an adolescent's
mental life is changing,
right away we need to
think in part that's
due to what's going
on in the body
and in particular what's
going on in the brain.
So for a child basically
what happens is this.
In utero-- and I don't
want to shock anyone--
but the sperm and
egg get together,
and they form a
single cell being
that then becomes 2 cells,
4, 8, 16, 32, 64, et cetera.
It gets bigger and
bigger and bigger
until it starts to
specialize in its function.
Some of those cells will
come from the outside
and become the neural tube
as they invaginate inward.
And that's important because
the nervous system, which
is this neural tube,
starts as skin cells.
And in fact the skin
is the interface
of the outer world
and the inner world.
And your nervous system,
including your brain,
is always about the interface
of the inner and the outer.
And that becomes extremely
important in understanding
adolescence.
That the nervous system is
basically fancy skin cells,
if you will, that are
always about saying,
what's going on inside?
What's going on outside?
How do I bring
those two together?
So what happens in utero
is that this nervous system
within the body is developing
a lot influenced by genes
and also of course the
stress of the mom, chemicals
that the mother may ingest.
Smoking, drinking,
different things
can affect the way this nervous
system is going to grow.
At birth, when we come now to
the structure of the brain,
let's take a look at it.
Basically it's
oriented like this.
The neural tube, the
spinal cord in your back,
will be represented
by your wrist.
The clump of neurons that
collects up in the head
that we'll just call the
brain has three major parts
that change a lot
in adolescence,
so we need to review them
to understand adolescence.
If you lift up your
top area-- try this out
so you can go with me.
Lift up your thumb area.
The first area is
the brain stem.
And this is the area that
regulates basic bodily
processes like what's going
on in the heart, the lungs,
the intestines.
And it also has
clusters of neurons
that control the reactive
states of the four F's
that you may be familiar with.
Some of them, fight,
flight, freeze, and faint.
So usually people
say fight, flight,
but it's actually two
other ones in addition.
Fight, flight, freeze--
tightening your muscles
when you're scared--
or fainting where
you're totally collapsing.
So those areas are
regulated by the brain stem,
very old, 300 million year old.
So it's called the
old reptilian brain.
And then if you come now
up in evolutionary terms
and also growing in utero
is the secondary area
of the brain called the
old mammalian brain.
You'd have two thumbs for
it to be a perfect model.
The thumb represent
the limbic area.
200 million years, it has
regions that you're probably
familiar with called the
amygdala, the hippocampus,
the hypothalamus, and
other regions as well.
The limbic area has
five big functions.
And we're going to
review them briefly
because to really
understand adolescents,
we need to understand what's
going on in the limbic area
and how it communicates with
the brain stem and the body.
So here are the functions.
And I'm going to just
point out how it develops
and then what changes
in adolescence so you
can understand it.
The first thing to say
is that this limbic area
is going to interact with
what's above it, the cortex,
we'll talk about later.
And what's below it, the
brain stem and the body.
So it's like a way
station that allows
all these different
inputs to be coordinated.
So if you're thinking
about what you do at Google
and how you're influencing
the sharing of energy
and information across
humanity, in many ways
the limbic area is going to
serve this kind of function
of pulling these
different things together.
So the limbic area is important
in working with the brain
stem and the body
in creating emotion.
So when you feel a big
feeling, a big emotion,
which adolescents
feel more of, it's
coming from the body, the brain
stem, and the limbic area.
And because those are all below
this higher area, the cortex,
it's called the subcortical
source of emotion.
Which is why when
computer programmers think
about creating
emotion in a computer,
I always discuss
with them, well,
you probably need that
computer to have a body.
Because to really
really have emotions,
you need a heart, lungs,
intestine, muscles, bones,
hormones to have
a true experience
of what we experience as humans.
So the body comes up all sorts
of channels, the first layer
of this spinal cord
called lamina 1.
The 10th cranial nerve,
all the body input
comes up to the brain
stem and the limbic area,
and we get an emotion that way.
And then it pops up
into our higher areas
where we have
consciousness, the cortex.
So these subcortical things in
adolescence are more robust.
There's a kind of emotional
spark in adolescence.
So if you compare a
10-year-old to a 14-year-old,
they're very different
not just that they've
accumulated four
more years of life.
But these subcortical
areas are just more active.
And we'll talk about why that
would be a good thing soon.
OK, so emotion is number one.
Number two is motivation.
The limbic area
works with the brain
stem to motivate people
to do different things.
And of course, the
motivation of a 14-year-old,
as any middle school
teacher will tell you,
is very different
from a 10-year-old.
That's because the limbic
area is changing dramatically
for very important
and good reasons.
Then when parents
don't understand them,
they clamp down on what's
happening to the adolescent
instead of supporting them.
And what the
"Brainstorm" approach
that we're going to
talk about can do
is change our whole
cultural conversation
so we recognize what's happening
in the brain and support
adolescents rather than
try to imprison them.
The third thing the
limbic area is involved in
is called appraisal.
Appraisal, and I don't know what
the computer equivalent would
be, but appraisal
is basically where
you're evaluating the
significance of something
happening.
So the first layer
of appraisal says,
is this thing
happening something
I should invest
energy and time in?
Like right now I'm appraising
my voice is getting hoarse,
so I'm going to get my water
bottle that my daughter gave me
before she went away to school.
And now my limbic
area will appraise
how did my voice sound?
And it sounds better,
so I put this down.
So that would be an appraisal.
I'm paying attention
to something.
The second thing
is, is the thing
I'm paying attention
to good or bad?
And if it's good, how
do I get more of it?
If it's bad, how do
I get less of it?
And those are basic appraisal
functions of the limbic area.
So that's number three.
Number four is different
kinds of memory
are mediated through
the limbic area.
We won't talk about
that, but the hippocampus
plays an important
role in creating
factual memory or
autobiographical memory
rather than just kind
of the visceral memory
that you have called
implicit memory.
And number five is attachment.
This becomes extremely
important in adolescence.
Attachment is what
we have as mammals.
This is the old mammalian brain.
Attachment is where, as a kid,
you rely on another person,
your parent usually,
an attachment figure,
to give you four S's.
They see you.
They keep you safe.
They soothe you.
And they give you an
internal feeling of security
if you have the first three.
So being seen means
someone identifies
what's going on
beneath your behavior.
Not just seeing your
body move, but thinking
about your feelings, identifying
what you're thinking about,
what has meaning for
you, what your needs are.
That's what I mean
by being seen.
Safe means two things.
They protect you from harm, and
they aren't a source of terror.
And if they are, they repair
that rupture very quickly.
Because any parent can lose it,
but if you lose it as a parent,
and I talk about this
in a book I wrote
called "Parenting from the
Inside Out" with Mary Hartzell.
If you lose it and
don't make a repair,
your child will have a
very negative outcome
in their attachment category
that they developed.
And that's explored in
all these different books
and in "Brainstorm" too.
So safe means not being
a source of terror
and also protecting
your child from danger.
So if you are seen,
and if you are safe,
and if when you're distressed
you're soothed-- that is,
I have a really
uncomfortable feeling.
I'm just a kid.
I don't know how to get
this feeling to feel better.
It just feels bad,
whether I'm sad,
angry, frightened,
whatever it is.
I go to this other person,
my attachment figure.
They do something with me.
They hug me.
They talk to me.
They just listen to
me and hear my story.
And I feel better.
An attachment figure soothes
the person who's attached.
OK, so what's so important
about this in adolescence?
And it's what you
said before, Ron.
When you're a kid and
you're distressed,
who do you go to for soothing?
Your parents, your
attachment figure.
But when you're an adolescent,
who do you tend to go to?
Your peers, and that is
a healthy, natural change
that if a parent is not aware
that this is going to happen,
they start feeling
left out and rejected
and think there's
something wrong.
When in fact it's
something right,
because overall what the
adolescent is preparing to do
is to leave home.
So picture this.
Just so you can understand
the attachment shift,
just imagine this scenario.
You're in bed.
You're sleeping really deeply.
The light comes streaming
in through the closed blinds
of your window, and
someone comes in your room.
Let's say it's your mom.
Someone who loves you
like crazy gives you
a kiss on the forehead and
says, good morning sweetie.
And you begin to
rouse, and she goes,
what would you
like for breakfast?
And you go, I'll have
some oatmeal, mom.
And she shouts down to your dad,
so-and-so would like oatmeal.
And so your dad starts
preparing oatmeal.
You come downstairs.
You have your pajamas on.
You have your oatmeal.
You then get dressed.
Maybe you watch a
little TV or you
start getting ready for school.
Then you go off to preschool.
And at preschool, you
play with friends,
and you learn how to share,
and you have a snack,
and maybe you come
home for lunch.
You're getting a little
tired, so you take a nap.
And then you play some
more out in the yard.
And then you have
another snack, and then
you dance around with
your mom, or your dad,
or who's ever there.
And then you get
a little hungry,
so they make you dinner.
And then you're
getting a little tired.
You get in the bathtub.
They scrub you down.
And then they put you in
bed, give you a massage,
read you a story,
and sing you a song.
And you fall off to sleep.
Now, if you kept
the same child mind
that was soaking that in
that the majority of kids
actually get--
maybe not everyone--
but who in their sane
mind would leave that?
Right?
Now, I know a lot of adults
who are trying to get that back
from their partners, which
is probably a good idea.
But as an adolescent,
if you think about it,
nature's got to do something
to the brain to say,
I know that's a pretty
good setup you got.
But I need you to go
from the familiar home,
where you're comfortable
and where you're safe,
to try something that's
unfamiliar, that's
uncomfortable, that's
uncertain instead of certain,
and that's potentially unsafe.
So what are you
going to do if you're
nature to make sure that this
kid when he's 55 years old
isn't still living at home?
You've got to do
something to this brain.
That's what we're going
to look into the details.
So part of it is you make
the emotions revved up.
Because emotion in many
ways is evoking motion.
It gets the being with the
emotion to do something.
That's what really emotion
is all about, evoking motion.
So we know that's going on.
The limbic area
attachment is changing,
so it says, hey, I'm not going
to turn to my parents anymore.
I'll use them as an ATM
machine and a driver.
But they're not going to
be my source of support.
They're not going to
be my homies anymore.
I'm going to find some
other people with whom
I turn to when I need support,
because they're getting ready.
So this is very, very important.
Now, if you bend your
fingers over the top,
this is the cortex.
This is the outer
bark of the brain.
That's what cortex mean.
It's sometimes called
the neo-mammalian cortex.
So the limbic area is
the old mammalian brain,
200 million years old.
The cortex is the
new mammalian brain.
The frontal area would be from
your last knuckles forward,
is the largest in primates.
And the front of the front
area is the most elaborated
in human beings.
It's called the
prefrontal cortex.
It's what you hear
about all the time.
It's why we have such
big foreheads compared
to our ape cousins.
We have this very elaborated
prefrontal cortex.
So the frontal area
in general allows
you to think, conceive
of things, program,
think about history, think
about coming here to a meeting,
and bringing lunch,
and making sure you
get to the next appointment
on time, all this stuff.
So the frontal area
is really important.
And this is the area
that matures last.
So what happens in
this adolescent brain
is basically this.
In utero, the brain
stem is well developed.
The limbic area is
partially developed.
The cortex is based
undeveloped at birth.
What this means is that
once the baby is out,
interactions with the
world in addition to genes
will influence the way
neurons connect to each other.
So neurons firing leads
to neurons rewiring.
And Eric Kandel won the
Nobel Prize for this in 2000
showing that when you
get neurons to fire off,
they actually activate
genes in a way that
gets them to increase their
connections to each other,
increase even
their myelin, which
is like a sheath that increases
the speed of interconnection
among the neurons the way they
communicate with each other.
100 times faster
and 30 times shorter
refractory period, resting
period between firings.
So 100 times 30 is 3,000.
When you've myelinated
neurons, you basically
are allowing them to be
coordinated and efficiently
communicating with each
other 3,000 times more.
So when you watch
people do the Olympics,
those Olympic athletes have
been practicing something
for so many hours,
they've laid down myelin.
Because skill building is
based on myelin growth.
So here's what
happens in childhood.
For the first dozen years,
more or less, this brain
is like a sponge.
It just soaks in
adult knowledge,
soaking in, soaking
in, soaking in.
But then nature does
something really interesting.
Instead of just having
the neurons build
their synaptic connections with
each other pretty progressively
throughout childhood,
once the switch happens--
and this is only something we've
known for the last 15 years.
The studies at my
university, UCLA,
and also National
Institute of Mental Health,
we've studied kids across
the developmental period
and have found the
following shocking findings.
The remodeling that no one
expected to be happening-- we
just thought the brain would
continue to grow new stuff,
and people thought it
was raging hormones
that would drive an
adolescent mad, which
is a second myth we're
going to bust right now.
The changes in adolescence are
not due to raging hormones.
Puberty happens,
and hormones rise.
But I don't even know what
a raging hormone would be.
Hey, I' a hormone,
and I'm really mad.
What does it mean to
be raging hormones?
It's not from raging hormones,
but everyone believes that.
And of course, if it
is raging hormones,
there's absolutely nothing
you as a parent or you
as an adolescent
can do about it.
I'm walking around
in this body, and I
got these hormones that
are raising out of control,
so of course I don't
know what I'm doing.
I've got raging hormones.
But if it's the brain, no matter
how that brain is changing,
we now know what you do
with your mind can change
the function and even the
structure of your brain.
So the empowerment that
we're about to talk about
is profound.
It clarifies what the
myths are, but the truths
turn out to be liberating.
So the first thing that was
found which shocked everyone
was that the brain,
instead of to continue
to develop synaptic
connections, actually
starts destroying them.
It's called pruning.
The brain starts to
eliminate not only
the synaptic connections that
were laid down, some of them,
but it actually starts
destroying neurons themselves.
You get less synaptic
connections, the connections
among neurons, and
even less neurons.
And everyone was going,
wow, what's going on?
And then as the adolescent
years progressed,
a second part of
remodeling happened.
Because the first is you're
getting rid of basically
connections you don't need.
The second thing that's
part of remodeling
besides the first
part, pruning, is
that you start to lay
down myelin in a big way.
So the adolescent brain
is going to become
more specialized by getting
rid of circuits it doesn't need
and then more efficient in its
coordination and balance-- more
integrated, if you will--
by taking the remaining
connections and allowing
them to be 3,000 times better
at communicating
with each other.
So the second dozen
years of life, of course
you continue to learn
with laying down
new synaptic connections.
But you're going from being
a generalist of a child
to a specialist
of an adolescent.
Now, what this means
for an adolescent--
and I wrote the "Brainstorm"
book for both adolescents
and adults to read-- for
the adolescent reading it,
I say to them
directly, because there
is no book, for anybody
there's no book written
about these brain changes
for the general public.
There's nothing.
And I wanted something to be
available for my own kids,
or their friends, or
people I work with.
I'm an adolescent psychiatrist.
So an adolescent
themselves could read this
and know from the inside
out what's going on.
When you go around to
high schools, which
I'm doing a lot
lately, I say, what
have you been taught
about the brain?
And this is what the
kids say, whether it's
7th grade or 12th
grade, nothing.
They've been taught
nothing about their brain.
I mean, there are exceptions
in charter schools now,
but for the most part, people
are not taught anything
about their brain, which is
amazing because we know a lot.
And when you know
about the brain,
you can do something about
its function and structure,
even if you have
genetic risks going on,
as we're studying at UCLA.
So here's the deal.
Remodeling in the
adolescent brain
takes place starting around 12,
and it goes on to the mid-20s.
This is why I say adolescence
doesn't end when the 19 year
birthday follows the
year and you turn 20.
It doesn't end.
It's the mid-20s.
So this adolescent
period of remodeling
is happening all
through the mid-20s.
Now, that's really
interesting, because it
means that they're going
to be continuing changes.
So let's review some
of these basic myths.
We said number one, adolescence
is more than the teenage years.
Number two, we said
that this period of time
is a time when the
brain is changing,
and it's not raging
hormones that
lead to the significant
changes of adolescence.
It's actually brain remodeling.
A third myth that
you may have heard,
which is what was said
in the introduction,
is many adults and
therefore the adolescents
who are hearing the
adults say this approach
adolescence with unbelievable
trepidation instead
of celebration.
And this trepidation
is that, oh my god,
it's going to be a
horrible period I've just
got to get through.
And what I want to
urge you to consider
is that in fact, what
I'm about to outline
suggests just the opposite.
It's a period you
can cultivate well
if you understand what's
happening in the brain.
And when you understand
what's happening in the brain,
you can actually
build these circuits
and make them stronger
intentionally.
So it's not a period
to just get through.
It's actually period to
celebrate and cultivate.
So that's a third myth.
A fourth myth is that
the adolescent period
is a period of
risk, which is true.
That's not a myth, but
only because adolescents
are impulsive.
And I want to describe
one thing that nature
does beyond impulsivity.
So early teenage
years, it's true.
Adolescents do not have a
space between an impulse
and an action as much
as they will later on.
But here's the story that is
kind of shocking as a parent.
And for those you who
have younger kids,
I don't want to scare you,
but this is just the truth.
Adolescents are three times
more likely during the period
12 to 24 to be seriously injured
or die from preventable causes.
Even though their body is much
stronger than any other time,
not only stronger
in muscle strength,
but if you get an
infection, it's
better to be an adolescent.
You can fight it better
than a kid can, a child,
or better than an adult can.
So they have stronger
bodies but three times
more likely to get
seriously hurt or die.
Now, why is that?
Part of it is impulsivity.
That part is true.
But it turns out there's
something else that
has been discovered that
blew everybody away too.
And it has a weird
name, but it's
called hyper-rational thinking.
And if you think
about it this way,
hyper-rational thinking is
driven by two processes.
One is a limbic process.
We talked about the
limbic area having
an evaluative system that works.
And the evaluation of the
limbic area during adolescence
is very different from adulthood
and different from childhood.
And basically nature
did this, said, OK,
let's say I'm an adolescent
who's 19 years old.
And my parents-- and sadly
this is a true story,
but I'm going to get inside the
head of the kid, which we don't
know-- my parents give me a
car that's really fun to drive.
And I think driving this
car 100 miles an hour
down Wilshire Boulevard is
going to be really cool.
Now, for me to take
the risk of doing
that, which on the one
hand, you could say, well,
if you're trying to get
this kid ready to experience
the unfamiliar, the
uncomfortable, the uncertain,
and the dangerous,
to leave home,
you got to do
something to the brain
to get me to do
dangerous things, which
is basically true.
If I don't take risks I'm
never going to leave home.
So I got to take risks.
So it takes this evaluative
circuit and says,
what's the upside of doing that?
Well, the upside is my
friends will think I'm cool,
which is great because
I want to have friends,
because having friends
will keep me alive.
So that's good.
And it'll be really exciting.
Because I was playing
these video games driving
100 miles an hour.
That was fun.
So this car will be
just like an elaboration
of the video game I was playing.
And what's the downside of that?
I could run into somebody.
I could get killed.
I could kill somebody.
So what happened to me
when my son was one,
so a long time ago now,
is my favorite professor
was pulling out of
his house, and he
was run over by a
19-year-old driving
95 miles an hour on a surface
street not far from here.
And he was just
killed instantly.
And I felt terrible
obviously for my professor,
for his family, for
the whole field.
He was a major figure
in our discipline.
But for the kid,
he's not a bad kid.
He had what was called
hyper-rational thinking.
He got the idea of
driving 100 miles an hour.
He actually planned it.
This wasn't impulsive.
And he knew about the dangers.
This is the thing, another myth.
Adults say, well,
adolescents just don't know.
Let's just inform
them of the dangers.
But actually they
know about dangers.
Their limbic area just skews
the balance that says, yeah,
I know about that.
But this would be so much fun.
They just don't care
about the danger.
So what I suggest in
the book, and there
are exercises called mindsight
exercises teaching about seeing
your own mind clearly
or other people's mind,
is if that kid had had
an internal compass that
wasn't driven by his
limbic area and cortical
processing of
information but instead--
and this is now we're just
beginning to learn about
this-- literally there
are Parallel Distributed
Processors-- PDP processors--
around the intestine
and around the heart.
The intrinsic nervous
system of the heart
and the nervous system
around the intestines
are PDP processors.
You know about PDP right?
So PDP can process information.
It doesn't do it with
logical reasoning.
It's not a logical formula.
But it has a deep
source of wisdom.
And what initial
findings suggest
is that kids who are in
touch with literally what
their gut is telling them and
what their heart is telling
them would choose not to
drive a car that fast.
Even though their
cortex would say,
yeah, that sounds
like a great idea.
What's wrong with it?
And their limbic area skew would
say, yeah, that sounds cool.
100 miles an hour,
you can do it.
You did it in the video game.
Why can't you do it in a car?
It's the same thing really.
Steering wheel, gas
pedal, what's the problem?
Your gut would
tell you something
doesn't feel right about this.
And I am choosing not to do it.
Because adolescents have
a natural, as you can see,
push against the
status quo of adults.
So if an adult policeman
says, the law is
you have to go 35 miles
an hour down Wilshire,
or to your parent says, hey,
you could have this car,
but don't drive fast.
There's a part of an
adolescent brain which
is literally programmed from
millions of years of evolution
to say, I don't care about that.
I know about what they said,
but I don't care about it.
Even to the point where you
probably know this study,
but let's say kids who are
going to pick up smoking.
They learn to smoke
usually during adolescence.
So they figured out, how can we
get adolescents not to smoke?
And what did they do?
They showed them
pictures of graveyards
to scare them and say,
look, if you smoke,
this is what your lung
is going to look like.
It's going to have big
holes in it, cancer, black,
all this stuff.
No drop in smoking.
They said, look, it's not good.
It's not even so cool to
smoke, no drop in smoking.
So what would you do if you're
a creative advertisement person
to try to make adolescents
not pick up smoking
or if they picked it up stop it?
You could have the parents
smoke and they'd say I wouldn't.
It's like that.
It's just like that, exactly.
So they did something like that.
They said, hey,
hey, did you know
that those really rich adults
who own the cigarette companies
know it's going to get
your body addicted,
and they're stealing your
money and laughing all the way
to the bank because
they want to get
you to be addicted to this crap?
And the kids stopped smoking.
They said, I'm not going to
let the adults do that to me.
It was brilliant,
absolutely brilliant.
Because they understood
the whole thing.
Now, speaking of
addiction we've talked
about hyper-rational functioning
of the cortex and limbic area.
The second reason kids
are doing risky behavior
is really important
to identify, and it
relates to addiction
too, is there's
a circuit that's distributed
up from the brain
stem, the limbic area of
the cortex called the reward
circuit.
You've probably heard about this
because it's in the news a lot.
It's driven by a
neurotransmitter.
The chemical allows the
neurons to communicate
with each other called dopamine.
And what nature has done
with the reward circuit
is basically some
studies suggest
dropped the baseline
levels of dopamine
and raised the release level.
And you could say,
why would you do that?
Well, partly the
reason to do that is
one of the major things that
gets dopamine to be released,
which this adolescent
would be more driven to
because they're kind of bored
because their baseline is low
and they want to
do something, one
of the major things that
releases it is novelty.
Novelty, doing something new
gets the dopamine released.
So you want to do something
new and create something new,
always be challenged.
That's fantastic.
So that's another
way that nature
gets a kid who's now an
adolescent to do risky things
and feel kind of, let's see,
without trying something.
And when parents realize
this, and the beautiful thing
about the book is now that it's
out, is when parents read this
and they have their
adolescents read it,
people are going
to understand, OK,
there's a natural drive
to push toward novelty.
And you can do it in
a constructive way
or just say, oh, that's bad.
And then the adolescent
will do things
that are really dangerous.
So there's a way of building
in healthy novelty exploration.
So those are the two ways,
hyper-rational cortical limbic
functioning and changes in
the dopamine reward circuitry.
Now, sadly, just to make sure
we talk about some downsides
here, because the
dopamine system
is the number one system
involved in anything that you
can get addicted to, whether
it's video games, or gambling,
or high sugar content foods, or
cocaine, or heroin, or alcohol,
every single one of
those things that you
can get addicted to captures
your dopamine circuit.
This is why we believe
adolescents are absolutely
the most vulnerable
to become addicted.
If you're going to become
addicted to something
in your life, it's most likely
to happen during this period,
likely because of
this dopamine change.
So we want to try to understand
that, not just ignore it,
and do something
positive to support it.
So let me summarize
all these brain
changes in the
following four elements.
We're going to look at
the upside and downside.
And then I want you to think
about these four elements
I'm about to talk about and how
they relate to your life now
an adult-- because
I'm looking around.
I think most people are adults.
There may be a couple of
adolescents in the room--
but also to remember
your own adolescence.
OK, so, I'm kind of
an acronym addict.
So luckily this
forms an acronym.
And if you had to ask
yourself the question, what
is the essence of what
Dan said, or what's
the essence of adolescence?
It spells the word essence.
So this is useful.
So let's review what
we just covered.
So this is going to be a
review of all this stuff,
and it's going to look at the
upsides and downsides of each
of these four things.
The first is E-S,
Emotional Spark.
We've said that the subcortical
regions, the body, the brain
stem, and the
limbic area, nature
has made more active
in an adolescent.
And this has the downside
with this more motion
is that adolescents
can be moody.
They can be irritable.
As one adolescent told
me to write in the book,
sometimes we feel one way.
Sometimes we feel another
way, and chill out.
They want the adults to know
not take it so personally.
These emotions are
big, and they're hard.
It can be really disorienting to
have so many big emotions going
on.
And that's a natural
part of evoking motion
that nature's created.
It isn't a problem unless
we make it a problem.
Now, some kids
can get depressed.
They can develop all
sorts of disorders.
In fact, the pruning
process is one reason
we believe that all of the
major psychiatric disorders
like schizophrenia, or
depression, or manic depressive
illness have their
onset in adolescence,
because the pruning is carving
away vulnerable circuits.
We didn't understand
that before,
and now we believe that's
the major mechanism.
The good news is we can
reverse that in many ways.
So early intervention
can be really important.
But anyway, the first
thing is emotional spark.
What's the upside of that?
This is a period where
life becomes on fire,
and you feel passionate
about something.
You really care about something.
And this passion fuels
a sense of vitality.
And the sad thing
is many adolescents
get crushed by adults'
response at home
and adults' response in
school and in society.
And so this is really sad,
because then of course
you will get
demoralized and feel
disempowered and
disenfranchised.
So the opportunity, for
example here in an organization
like Google, is
to think about how
to shift the culture of
conversation about adolescents.
And it's a huge opportunity
to change the way we
as a culture approach
this period of time.
So E-S, emotional spark.
S-E, Social Engagement,
the adolescent, as we said,
because of these
limbic changes, is
driven to be more with
peers than their parents.
And that's healthy.
That's normal.
That's fine.
Adolescents need their peers
to survive out in the world.
Peer group membership
is important.
What's the downside?
If you give up morality
for membership,
then peer pressure will crush
your internal sense of values.
So membership is
really important.
Parents need to realize that.
So when a kid comes
to you and says,
I need to go to this party.
Joe and Sammy are all
going, and I got to go.
I got to go.
You need to understand when
your adolescent feels like it's
a matter of life and death,
that's from millions of years
of evolution that tells
them if they're not
a member of a group,
they are likely to die.
They're not just making that up.
It's not just west Los Angeles
culture or something like that.
It's in their genes.
Now, that doesn't mean you need
to let them go to the party.
Or if they say, I need to
wear a certain-- well, not
these shoes, but a certain
kind of shoe or I'm
not going to fit in, it's
a life and death matter.
That's how it feels.
You can accept the feeling even
if you don't purchase the shoe.
So that's a really big step in
increasing the communication
across the generational divide.
Now, the upside of
social engagement
is that every research
study, every single one
on your medical health, on
your mental health, on how long
you live and your happiness,
without exception,
every single one show
that the number one
factor is supportive
relationships.
You begin to learn to
move away from your family
and develop these social
networks of support
in adolescence.
So these are skills
that can last a lifetime
and be incredibly positive.
So social engagement is S-E.
What's N?
So E-S, emotional spark,
S-E, social engagement,
N is Novelty.
Novelty, as we said, the
dopamine system change
gets you to try new things.
The downside of it, you
can do risky things,
and you have unfortunately this
increased risk of getting hurt.
Right?
What's the upside?
The upside is
novelty is exciting.
It allows you to be
driven to try new things,
to do new things, to
take risks, to be brave,
to be courageous, to live with
this kind of sense of gusto.
And that's great.
So we have to learn to manage
this novelty-seeking drive.
And finally C-E, what is it?
C-E is Creative Explorations.
The creative exploration
of the adolescent brain
is to try to push against
the adult status quo.
And nature has designed this
from a large evolutionary point
of view for the
following reason.
Basically as a child,
you're the sponge
soaking in the adult world.
As adults, you figure out
what the world is like,
and you try to find
your niche in it.
You go home.
You're tired.
You want to collapse.
You watch TV, in a modern times.
If we did not as a species have
the adolescent period of time,
we would never be
as adaptive as we
are to an ever-changing world.
You need to have a continual
source of individuals,
children now turned
adolescents, who
approach the status quo
and say, I don't buy it.
I don't buy this.
I'm not going to
settle for this.
I am going to try to
create a new world.
I am going to adapt to
the world that's here
and make my own world.
So if you think about art,
and if you think about music,
and if you think about
science, and if you
think about technology, you know
that all the major innovations
primarily come from
adolescent minds.
Now, think about it.
That's creative explorations.
Now, what's the downside of it?
The downside of creative
exploration is as a child,
you just say, hey, this is
the world I'm being given.
I'm learning to a
deal with it, learning
to deal with it,
fine, fine, fine.
But then when you get to be
an adolescent, you go, hey.
This world I'm being given,
it's kind of not so good.
In fact, it sucks.
In fact, I've got
to try to change it.
And that's a burden, and
it can be disorienting.
It can be frightening.
So we need to
realize, especially
in these days when so much
information is being shared,
and as you probably know--
I don't remember the ratios.
You can tell me-- we get
information now in a week--
I think it's a
week time, right?--
that is more information
than 100 years ago,
people would get in a lifetime.
I think that's the ratio,
something like that.
So think about an
adolescent who's
just emerging from childhood
who was built on the net, right?
Who's soaking in all the
stuff, and their brain's
being flooded by
all the changes that
are going on in Somalia, in the
Ukraine, in the whole world.
Everything is blowing up, and
people are killing each other.
I mean, it is overwhelming.
But 100 years ago, it
was nothing like that.
We have this longer period of
adolescence now, of course,
because adolescence used to be
a lot shorter, a couple years.
Now it's a dozen years or more.
So we have this long
period of adolescence,
and what's happening now is
adolescence is being filled
with this stuff at a
time when they realize
they are going to be
responsible for this world
and they don't just
accept it as is.
So that's the downside.
What's the upside?
Creative explorations allows
us to create a new world.
So what I do when
I speak to schools,
and I want to have
you consider this,
is if we change the
cultural conversation
around adolescence, two
big things can happen.
Number one for
adolescents themselves,
if we change the way the
curriculum addresses this--
and now there's a province up in
Canada, a school district here
in the United States,
and in a couple
individual schools
in the US too where
we're thinking about making
a "Brainstorm" approach
to middle school
and high school.
You would say, instead of
doing the same old thing you'd
do for a younger
child, you would
say, let's build on the
emotional spark, the passion,
and have kids approach, let's
say, the world's problems
of what they feel
really compelled
to really try to improve.
Famine, violence,
climate change, then I
say, OK, then what would you
do with social engagement?
That's the emotional
spark piece.
The social engagement,
instead of having
to compete with each
other, where you say,
hey, do the best on
the spelling bee.
Get the best grades.
Get the best SAT scores so you
can get in the best college
so you can get in
the best graveyard.
That's basically what
we're telling them really.
But instead, we are a
collaborative species.
And not much is done
in school to build
on our collaborative nature
that's inherent to adolescents.
So what if you say, OK, instead
of competing with each other,
if you have a competitive
streak that's beautiful,
let's compete with
the world's problems.
And let's get together in
groups of collaborative nature
where we know from studies
collective intelligence rises
above individual
intelligence every time.
So let's have you actually
build with each other
so that when you beat the
competition, everybody wins.
That's the kind of setup
which would be win-win.
And I'll bet you that when you
allow the adolescent mind that
moves towards novelty and has
creative explorations built
into these millions
of years of evolution,
I'll bet you you're
going to find solutions
to some of these world problems
that we adults have never
been able to solve.
These are some of the world's
most pressing problems,
and there's an untapped resource
of incredible creativity
and courage.
So that's for the adolescents.
It's an incredible
opportunity to empower them.
And in the "Brainstorm" book, I
have these mindsight exercises
that allow the adolescent or
the adult reading the book
to actually build the
integrative fibers of the brain
than are the basis
of well-being,
emotional intelligence, and
also the basis of innovation
that they can
actually build them.
So that's for the adolescent.
The final thing I want
to say is think about it
for your own life.
How many people do
you know as adults
who made it through adolescence
but they lost their essence?
They lost their emotional spark.
They've lost social
support, social engagement.
They don't do new
things in their life,
and they aren't creatively
challenging their mind
with creative exploration.
And they've lost the essence
of living a vital life.
When I was writing this
up, I went, oh my gosh,
because I'm very familiar with
a field called neuroplasticity,
which is how we as adults
keep our brain continually
growing strong
throughout the lifespan.
And in a book
called "Mindsight" I
show you how you do that even
with someone in their 90s.
So we know that for sure.
What you do in your mind
can keep your brain strong.
If you had to pick the top
four aspects of life that
will keep your brain
growing strong and even
being integrated, it
would be emotional spark.
Keep passion in your
life for what you do.
Social engagements, keep
your social connections,
the network of
support really strong.
Novelty, give your brain
new things it does.
Try new activities.
And creative explorations,
challenge your mind
in ways that are not
just the status quo
but really keep you
pushing the boundaries.
Emotional spark,
social engagement,
novelty, creative
explorations, exactly what
we need as adults too.
And then I realized,
wow, maybe some adults
I've seen over these 25
years of being in practice,
maybe they're angry
at their adolescents.
Outside of their awareness
but deep in their hearts,
they know this adolescent has
an essence that they themselves
have lost.
So what I say to the
adult very gingerly who's
also reading the book so they
won't just toss it in the trash
can, I say, look,
if this essence
is something you would like
to get back, if you follow
these exercises too,
you can get it back too.
It's never too late to
revive your essence.
I know for a fact you can
take someone even in their 90s
and revive it.
And so when we do this
then, the exciting thing
is everybody wins.
You improve the relationship
between adults and adolescents.
You'll tap into an
incredible resource
of innovation,
courage, and creativity
in the adolescent group.
You'll allow the adult
who's lost their essence
to get really revived.
And so everybody wins.
So the exciting thing
is getting this change
in the cultural conversation
for adolescents and adults
out in the world.
And the great news is
if we do that, there's
this incredible opportunity
to actually make
this world a better place
for all of us to live.
So thank you so much
for your attention,
and we have time for discussion.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You
talked about pruning
and then the myelin
growth stage.
Do you know when those
two stages tend to occur?
DANIEL SIEGEL: Yeah, they're
a little different male
and female.
So female starts about a year
and a half sooner than males.
And when you watch the path,
they happen differently.
But basically, it's the first
few years is a lot of pruning,
and the pruning
sort of comes down.
And then the myelination,
which is the white matter
or the brain, is
increasing later on.
So if you saw a
graph, it would be
kind of overlapping like that.
So the first two, three, four
years, a lot, a lot of pruning.
And then you see the following
years a lot of myelination.
And the myelination
goes on into the 20s.
Now, here's the thing.
This is sort of a myth, but
it's just a misconception.
People say, oh, the prefrontal
cortex is just immature.
That's why adolescents
are immature.
And I really think we should
stop using the word immature.
Because immature
applies you are one
place only because
you're getting
ready to go somewhere else.
I think the adolescent period is
a period where you're basically
growing these integrative
fibers throughout the brain.
And so the brain is
becoming more integrated.
And the prefrontal cortex is
like a profound integrative
area that's just making sure
all the other regions that
are growing.
So you really have to
look at specific areas,
and they're a little
different male and female.
But if you look at the graph,
you can see it that way.
And I can refer
you to some papers.
AUDIENCE: And one
follow-up based
on that is should you be
doing something different
as a parent during
those different stages?
Or do you kind of consider
that all part of adolescence?
DANIEL SIEGEL: You mean
pruning and myelination?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEGEL: Well,
they go together.
But here's the way I
would think about it.
I would think that, and what
I would say to the adolescent
as a parent of an
adolescent is, it's a use it
or lose it principle.
So I'd say to a kid who's into
music, if you really like music
and you're 12, 13 years
old, pruning happens.
And basically nature
is going to say,
if you're not using a
certain circuit, dump it.
You don't need it.
So this period of adolescence,
I say to my adolescents,
is, if you really like
music, just exposure yourself
to a lot of music.
Play a lot of music.
Do music.
That's great.
Do it.
Because this is
the time your brain
is going to be specializing.
I would let them know that.
Same thing with athletics,
same thing with anything.
That's a good time
to do something.
The myelinating is by practice,
you actually lay down myelin.
And so I would just say
that and then back off.
So it isn't like you say,
you should be doing this.
You should say, this is
information you should have,
and you make your decision.
That's a very different
thing than saying,
let's avoid pruning.
Let's avoid-- every morning.
And some adolescents
have told me
they're a little worried
about the pruning.
And so you want to say,
you can use your mind
to keep those circuits going.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I find it
fascinating about the PDP
process in your heart or gut.
In that sense, you mentioned
the example the adolescents are
actually know from those part
that the danger, the risk.
DANIEL SIEGEL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
practical implication?
DANIEL SIEGEL: So the practical
thing is this-- yes, very good.
So you have your intestines,
and you have your heart.
And they're going to
process information.
There is a pathway from these
PDP processors up lamina 1,
layer one of the spinal cord,
and up the 10th cranial nerve,
the vagus nerve.
You don't need to remember.
If you want to know those
details, they're there.
But anyway, they're basically
very limited pathways
that come up.
They come up into the brain
to a very specific area called
the anterior insula and
the anterior cingulate.
For most people, the way
you get the processing
that goes on there into the
part of the brain, this cortex
that's going to make ultimate
decisions, go, no go.
Do I do it?
Do I not do it?
Let's say for the
driving, you can
have the processing going on.
But the pathway to this
prefrontal decision-making
circuit is not well developed.
So even though their gut would
be processing don't do it,
their cortex would never
receive the signal.
So in the book,
I teach exercises
where we know how to
increase the anterior insula
activity and size.
And I put them in the book.
Literally we now know-- this
is the amazing thing-- we now
know if you do this exercise,
you will stimulate the-- I
call it SNAG-- Stimulate
Neuronal Activity Growth.
You're going to SNAG
the anterior insula
so that when you
stimulate to grow studies
show it will not only fire.
You get it to fire.
Neurons which fire together wire
together is the fun statement.
And you get it to grow.
Then that kid-- we
need to do the studies,
but this is what I
suggest in the book
because all the research
points in this direction--
is that the person who has
that kind of mindfulness,
that kind of reflection,
that kind of interoception
is what it's called, they will
allow the wisdom of the body
to influence the cortical
circuits of decision.
Does that make sense?
So you're basically
strengthening--
I don't know if the computer
analogy-- you're strengthening
the PDP processing
in one region that's
geographically
separate from another.
And you're laying
down the cables
and so that it reaches
the ultimate decision--
because this doesn't
make decisions.
This makes decisions what
the body is going to do.
This doesn't do that.
So we want to have
this have literally--
and what I teach the
adolescent reading is I say,
this is how it works.
Your cortex is vulnerable
because it's hyper-rational.
You want to let your own
wisdom, not your parents' rules,
not the law, because of course
you're pushing against those.
You want to let your own
wisdom be your guide.
I call that an internal compass.
That's how you develop it.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious what you
were saying about the drastic
link-
DANIEL SIEGEL: Come right up
to the mic so we can hear.
AUDIENCE: Curious about
the drastic lengthening
of the adolescence period.
You were saying it used
to be a couple years,
and now it's like a dozen years.
I assume that cultural factors
would have a big part of that.
But adolescence, as
you're defining it,
is really biological processes.
So what are the
interactions there?
DANIEL SIEGEL: Yeah,
it's a great question.
So let me just lay out
the facts as we know them.
The external marker that we use
from let's say 150 years ago
is the onset of puberty.
So puberty had its onset
around 15 or 16 years of age
150 years ago across
many cultures.
And for girls, it was about
a year, year and a half
before boys.
So there's a little bit
different male female
difference.
And then girls would actually
get married and settled
down around two years later
in terms of raising a family.
And boys would be maybe
two or three years later.
So for a female, the adolescent
period was about two years.
For males, about 3 1/2, 4 years.
That was basically
150 years ago.
What has changed
now is that puberty
just as a marker, rough marker,
has come from 15 or 16 down.
And now some girls are
having the beginning
of their menstrual cycle
around 11, 10, some even 9
for reasons we don't understand.
It looks like it's
related to nutrition.
Boys it's coming down early
about a year and a half
later in terms of development
of sexual maturation.
And roughly, it's
not exactly the same
because you can have someone
delay puberty who actually
has started adolescence
in the brain.
This is why we know they're
not exactly the same thing.
But as a rough estimate,
then this stretch
then where now you have people
starting the adolescent period
around 12, more or
less, they're not
assuming adult responsibilities.
And also the brain is
remodeling way into the mid-20s.
So this is definitely
culturally dependent.
If we could do these same
scans on people from Papua New
Guinea, maybe they'd
have a two-year period.
We'd have to look at that.
There's a center that we've
been running for 10 years called
the Center for Culture,
Brain, and Development.
And just to respond to your
really important big question,
culture shapes the timing
of brain development.
But the periods
that we go through
seem to be
biologically built in.
The question is their
onset and their offset
may be culturally determined.
AUDIENCE: So it's almost like
the adult responsibilities
kind of clamps down on this
process and terminates it.
DANIEL SIEGEL: Well, that
would be the interesting thing
to study subcultures where
people do settle down,
get married.
And we don't have enough
brain scans to see yet.
Absolutely, that
may be what happens.
And of course what we know is
that it's a cyclical thing.
What I write about,
which gets people
very interested in
this whole thing,
is that the mind is not
just about brain activity.
It's about what happens
in a culture too,
like what's shaped
by our information
sharing in the
internet, for example,
and what's shaped across
media and stuff like that.
So mental processes
are both cultural.
That is they're relational,
how we share information.
And they're embodied.
They're what's happening
throughout the whole body.
So when you look at it that
way and the developing mind
kind of explorers this, then
you realize, half of the story
is the body.
The other half is our relational
world of information sharing.
And so they
influence each other.
Yes, and we can do
one more question?
Yeah, great.
AUDIENCE: There's a
book I read a while back
called "Hold Onto Your
Kids" by Gabor Mate.
DANIEL SIEGEL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are you
familiar with it?
DANIEL SIEGEL: I know
Gabor, yeah, yes, I'm
familiar with it.
AUDIENCE: So the basic
premise I took away
from that was that the
attachment of adolescents
to peers should not be
encouraged but really
redirected to the
parents instead,
whereas you seem to say that
peer attachment is actually
the norm and actually
desirable for adolescents.
And how do you feel that
parents should approach this?
DANIEL SIEGEL: Yes, thank
you for pointing that out.
So first of all, what happens in
modern culture is-- and there's
a very important question
you were raising--
is that adolescents have
a natural push away.
In all cultures we've
been able to study,
so in our center, the Center for
Culture, Brain, and Development
at UCLA, we looked
at all cultures
that have been studied.
And every culture has
an adolescent period
where the adolescents
push against adults.
Now, it could be in
subtle ways like if you're
in a society where they're
weaving from the top down,
well, you're going to
weave from the bottom up.
That's your so-called
pushing away.
But in every society we're able
to study, there's a push away.
Now, in most
societies except ours,
there are non-parental
adults who
serve important mentor
relationships guiding
the development of adolescents.
That's extremely important.
But it's not the parent.
So where I would
disagree the Gabor,
and we had a talk about this
recently at a meeting up
in British Columbia, I don't
agree that it's unhealthy,
as he points out,
for adolescents
to push away from their parents.
I don't agree with that at all.
What I do agree with
is the sentiment
that adolescents should
be launched into the world
without any adult
involved with them.
The challenge we
have in this culture,
as you've seen from what
happened at Penn State
and what happens in some
religious organizations,
is when you get a non-family
member adult, sometimes even
a family member, involved
that's not a parent involved
in an adolescent's life,
there's abuse that goes on.
So understandably,
we as parents are
very concerned about when
you see an adult starting
to take on a mentor role with
an adolescent boy or girl.
So I don't have an
easy answer to this.
But the general issue is
adolescents need each other.
They need to have
attachment with each other.
It's extremely important
for their development.
And if you look at the work
of Susan Harter, H-A-R-T-E-R,
I think the research
absolutely bears that out.
They should be becoming
attached to each other.
It's a natural part of
millions of years of evolution
that that's a natural thing.
Should they push away completely
from adults, their parents
including?
Not at all, so that
I agree with Gabor.
For sure, they shouldn't
push away completely.
So the balance would
be how we as a society
can figure out how
do you have some kind
of institutionalized
mentor program
where you have
non-parental adults who
are an active part
of the essence
of adolescence supporting
and adolescent's growth?
So I think we need to get
our minds all together
saying, how are we
going to invent this,
minimizing the risks.
Because abuse is a serious risk.
I mean, just look at what
would happen in these things
I'm talking about.
So we need to do
it in a safe way,
but we absolutely need it,
because our culture basically
lacks it.
And in that sense,
it's really true.
We need to keep adults
involved in adolescents' lives
but also support them in having
attachments with each other.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, good, thank you.
RON: I have one final question.
DANIEL SIEGEL: Yes.
RON: This is Google, and
outliers are kind of the norm
here, so I would like to ask--
DANIEL SIEGEL: That's why I
feel so at home at Google.
RON: This onset at
12 and ending at 24,
what's the variability on that?
DANIEL SIEGEL: Yeah, so first
of all, saying it ends at 24
is an estimate of when
the remodeling generally
seems to come to some
kind of completion.
But the brain continues to
change throughout the lifespan.
So what I would say is this.
I would say adults who can hold
onto their adolescent essence
are going to live the
most vital kind of life.
And if you mean by an
outlier that you're
kind of thinking
outside the box,
and pushing the limit of
things, and all that's
a part of adolescent creative
explorations and novelty,
that's a beautiful thing.
And so the number 24 doesn't
mean adolescence should end.
So a lot of these talks,
people come to me,
I think I'm still adolescent.
I go, good for you.
So seriously, I mean,
it's a funny thing.
The word adolescence
has in some connotations
a negative spin, like, oh,
you're just adolescent.
What I hope we can do--
literally we as a society--
is change the
cultural conversation
where you realize the
essence of adolescence
is actually the
essence of adulthood.
And we shouldn't let it go.
And we should support people
who make the outliers really
be filled with
inspiration for everyone.
RON: Thank you.
Maybe the natural
follow-up question
is, do you have
people come up to you
and say, my spouse
is an adolescent,
and what can I do about that?
DANIEL SIEGEL: Yes, I do.
But that could be a lot of fun.
RON: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, and we'll
continue the conversation
outside, have book signing.
Thank you.
DANIEL SIEGEL: Thank you.